but uh yeah i think it's time to begin
so welcome to to the aging phase course
and we're going to live use a chapter
one together
and this is really the place to ask any
questions you might have
so please do so in the chat i'm going to
make some pose
every five to ten minutes and go through
the chats read the questions
and answer them to the best of my
knowledge
um so the urging phase course
and this session will go over chapter
one as i said and
uh this chapter is a very general
introduction
to what transformer models can do so you
don't need to worry about setting up
anything just yet
just a few cut samples we'll see how you
can run them in collab
directly or the green face website
i'm not gonna watch reviews introduction
video because you can do that on your
own time and there is not really
anything informative in it and so the
goal of the first section of the course
which is public right now which is this
section
uh in pink is to
introduce you to transformer models so
let's chapter one today and then teach
you how to download the pre-trained
model from the herb
fine tune it on your own data for text
classification tasks
and then upload the result back to the
model hub and
then see section two will dive a little
bit
deeper and consider all nlp tasks and
not just text classification
and then the last part of the course is
gonna dive
even a little bit deeper so part two
should be released in the fall and part
three should be released at the
beginning of next year
and so once you've finished this part of
the course you should be able to
download the pre-trained model finding
it on your own problem
and then create either a small app or
upload the result back to the hub
and so you should look at the forum
which i'm gonna
i'll show you just here at discuss the
living face.co
which is where you will be able to ask
any question you have
after this live stream in the course
category
there is one topic per chapter for all
your questions
and then there is also one topic uh i'm
going to follow very closely
which is the chair your projects topic
on which you should definitely share
anything you build
after following the first section of the
course
all righty
so let's dive in since i don't see any
general questions for now
with the beginning of
chapter one
[Music]
so
transformer models are all about doing
nlp tasks nlp stands for natural
language processing
and it's a field that's related to
everything uh
language so the war the goal of nlp task
is either to classify some texts
so for instance getting the sentiment of
a review detecting if an email is a spam
detecting if a comment someone posted
online is rather nice or
rather not nice if a sentence is
grammatically correct
etc etc our task could be classifying
each word
in the text so for instance being able
to pass
the grammatical components or to be able
to see if
that word is a person or location or an
organization
another type of nlp task is generating
text content
so completing a prompt which is what
your smartphone does
when you're trying to compose a message
usually it suggests user next words and
even
gmail does that now on email um
filling the blanks in text which is
another kind of text generation
another kind of task is to extract an
answer from a text so given a very long
text and then the question
being a ball a model being able to
extract
the answer to that model the answer to
that question sorry
from the context or generating these new
sentences from an input text so this is
for instance generating a translation of
a text or
summarizing the text i saw an article
very recently on
making a new text in another style for
instance a
casual style or more
formal style so those are all the kind
of nlp that we'll tackle
uh in the course especially in section
two
and so it's rather challenging because a
computer
doesn't process information the same way
as we do and so the new transformer
model
which is deep learning to
[Music]
are able to from like a few
from a few samples that you have labeled
for they're able to generalize properly
without you having to
to create um rules for instance uh so
before
before deep learning was all the rage
one thing would be to
to to pass the text and have some
special rows if i see this word maybe it
means it's positive if i see this word
maybe it means it's negative
etc extra so that's not what's done
uh now this is mostly using
transformer models with the face
library and uh those models
you should if you have not yet you
should spoil
an introduction to a deep learning
course those models are usually trained
and they don't follow a set of given
words that has been written by a human
they they have weights which have which
follow an algorithm called
gradient descent and following the
training
data that they're fed they make their
loss function or another metric
a little bit better at each step and so
we get at the end
a model that is kind of a black box
that we can use and generalize fairly
well
data that looks like the data on the
training step
so let's look at what this model can do
in practice
so there are two ways we'll be able to
do that the first way
is by clicking on this open in collab
button
so collab is a platform
maintained by google which
provides free access to resources like
gpus or tpus
in jupiter in a jupiter notebook
environment
so you can execute
code directly inside it
and so the first cell uh needs to be
executed to install other library i'm
going to let this run
while we go through a little bit of the
course and then uh
we'll be able to run the other code
samples i'm going to come back to that
window a little bit later
so transformers models are everywhere
they are used by a lot of companies now
these those are examples of company that
are using the
keyface model app to have to share as
models they have pre-trained
and probably to use them internally as
well and the transformers library
uh is the main influence library that
provides access to those models
and the model hub which we're going to
have a quick look
uh on a little bit later the model hub
is where all the spreadtrain models are
stored is part
of the evening phase ecosystem and we
will be able to run the same code
as we'll try in the in the collab
notebook on that modal hub a little bit
later
the thing you will need to do to access
the forum and to be able to play around
with all the models is create
a give a second following the link here
on the
under in the section three of the
chapter one
and so we'll have a look first at the
higher level
higher level api object which is called
the pipeline function
i'm gonna just give a little few minutes
i'm just gonna give a few minutes for
the video to
pose for the video to load itself a
little bit
and take the time to answer any
questions that you have
let me scroll through the chat
i saw there were a few
so the first question is is there still
a place for lcm models
approaches like olm fit if so where do
they outperform transformer models or at
least should be considered
that's a very very good questions very
good questions right and there is
definitely still a place for lstm model
and the main reason transformer models
are evenly used right now is that the
computation
is more efficient especially on hardware
like gpus and tpus
because use lstms rely on a recurrent
mechanism
and that requirement mechanism is a
little bit harder to optimize
but for instance volume fit has a very
good
state-of-the-art results on the mdp data
set which is classifying
movie reviews and it's
been only very recently that it was
outperformed but transformers on that
task
in may which i think is linked to the
fact that the emdb reviews
are very long and transformer models
are good with inputs that go up to the
sequence like we can manage
usually it's 512 but
412 tokens sorry but yeah if you have
things that are longer than that
it looks like lstm models can still be a
very good fit
another question i'm gonna answer it
just after this video because it's
about the pipeline so yeah let's watch
the video i'm gonna disappear from the
screen
so you can watch without me being in the
way and
i'll come back after the video
the pipeline function
the pipeline function is the most high
level api of the transformers library
it regroups together all the steps to go
from more text
to usable predictions the weather used
is at the core of a pipeline but the
pipeline also includes all the necessary
preprocessing
since the model does not expect texts
but number
as well as some post processing to make
the output of the model human readable
let's look at the first example where
the sentiment analyzes pipeline
this pipeline performs text
classification on a given input
and determines if it's positive or
negative
here it attributed the positive label on
the given text
with a confidence of 95 percent
you can pass multiple texts to the same
pipeline which will be processed
and passed through the model together as
a patch
the output is a list of individual
results in the same order as the input
text
here we find the same label on score for
the first text
and the second text is church negative
with a confidence of 99.9 percent
the zeroshot classification pipeline is
a more general text classification
pipeline
it allows you to provide the labels you
want here
we want to classify our input text along
the labels education
politics and business the pipeline
successfully recognizes
is more about education than the other
labels with a confidence of 84
moving on to other tasks the text
generation pipeline will auto complete a
given prompt
the output is generated with a bit of
randomness so it changes each time you
call the generator object
on a given prompt up until now
we've used pipeline api with a default
model associated to each task
but you can use it with any model that
has been retrained or fine-tuned on this
task
going on the model hub againfest.go
slash models
you can filter the available models by
task the default model to use in a
previous example
was gpt2 but there are many more models
available
and not just in english let's go back to
the text generation pipeline
and load it with another model distilled
jpg 2.
this is a lighter version of gpd2
created by the early phase team
when applying the pipeline to a given
prompt we can specify several arguments
such as the maximum length of the
generated text or the number of
sentences we want to return
since there is some randomness in the
generation
generating text by using the next word
in a sentence was the retraining
objective of gpd2
the field mass pipeline is a pretreating
objective of board
which is to guess the value of mass
words
in this case we ask the two most likely
values for the missing words
according to the model and get
mathematical or computational
as possible answers another task
transformers model can perform is to
classify each word in a sentence
instead of the sentence as a wall one
example of this
is named entity recognition which is a
task of identifying entities
such as persons organizations or
locations
in a sentence here the model correctly
finds the person
silva the organization again face
as well as a location brooklyn inside
the input text
the grouped entities equal two arguments
use is to make the pipeline group
together the different words linked to
the same entity
such as aging and face here
another task available with a pipeline
api is extractive question answering
providing a context and a question the
model will identify the span of text in
the context
containing the answer to the question
getting short summaries of very long
articles is also something the
transformers library can help with
with the summarization pipeline
finally the last task supported by the
pipeline api
is translation here we use a french
english model found on the model hub
to get the english version of our input
text
here is a brief summary of all the tasks
we've looked into in this video
try them out through the inference
widgets in the modern hub
[Music]
sorry about the sound at the beginning
uh
so i'm trying to guess but read wrong
apparently i can't have my eight foot
zone at the same time i'm playing the
video so
that part seemed to have been dealt with
and for the fact that it's laggy
and buffering a lot uh trying to find a
solution but i don't know what it could
be
let's hope it's gonna be a little bit
better at the next video i tried
minimizing
obs and hopefully it could be better
so the question i skipped before the
video was
when you do pipeline sentiment analysis
how can you determine which model it is
using
the dock string doesn't help much that's
true
it's not in the documentation and we
should probably make an effort
to have it better documented
the best way to do that is to inspect
the source code
for now which
i'm gonna show you in one second
so you need to go into pipelines in it
and if
that's a great question where actually
make it more accessible and easier to
see
but you need to go so in the source code
in the pipelines
module and in the init file and there
you will see
for each pipeline the default model that
is used
so here we were using uh the sentiment
text classification and sentimentalizes
have the same default and the model that
was used is distilled
based in case fine tune sss2 english
i don't know why the person didn't pick
a short name but
that's the name of it
let me see if there are any other
questions
yes i'll send the links of the next
video on the chat
or you can follow on the on the course
chapter at the same time and look at
them
directly in another brother further
okay it looks like there are no other
questions so let's continue
uh so this chapter so the rest of this
section is just the code samples that
were shown in the video so i'm not gonna
go through that
instead i'm gonna look at my collab
which hopefully
should have
i need to restart the runtime or lovely
so hopefully it's not going to take a
long time
to reinstall everything
why are you being mean with me okay
so for this could be a little bit
smoother for you
so we once we've installed the
transformers library we can run the
first cell for instance
uh which has the same code as in the
video
and uh yeah there is a bug with the last
version of torture which was just
released
now and so we can't run anything on
collab uh
so that's also lovely not sure if we can
uh get this
version somehow
[Music]
okay so hopefully the python works fox
will fix the bug uh
very soon and you will all be able to
run all the collab samples pretty easily
in the meantime i'm gonna try to show
you the same thing
in the tripita notebook and when i log
on
to something that can run it
okay
so let me just go
but not gonna be here
so if you prefer running notebooks
locally everything is in the repo called
notebooks
inside the egging face organization and
with this notebook your
core subfolder and then you have chapter
part chapter or directly for the videos
so let's look at the same notebook i was
trying to run in collab
zoom in a little bit
a little less okay so after running the
install which i don't need to do because
it may have
everything installed you can run the
code
that we are seeing on the video you can
play around and put another sentence try
several sentences at the same time
um try the zero shot classification
pipeline and all the pipelines we saw in
the video
the next uh the other way you could try
all of that
is a model hub
that i loaded
but they had it somewhere
you can go so the model is on face dot
co slash models
and there you can click on any model so
for instance if we go and did the
distilled
paste in case fine tuning sss to english
which we saw was the default model for
the sentiment analysis pipeline
we can go there and there is a small
widget where
we can try it on
any sentence
and get the same result so
you've got oh made a table so you got at
least three different ways of trying
all the code samples so on the with the
inference api on the website sometimes
when you are the
when you're trying a model you'll have a
small progress but here while it's
loading
and then you can try it on lots of
sentences in a way
um so
let's go back to the course
on the next section about how
transformer models work so transformer
models
are pretty recent so the architecture in
itself
was released in a paper in
2017 and then the first pre-trained
model
was gpt and was released by open ai in
june 2018.
the second pre-trained model was bought
released by google in october
2018 and then it kind of accelerated uh
like here are just a few samples of
model but there are many many more
uh that were released and even now so
we would need at least like to have this
image be twice or three times as big to
be able to put every model
that was released between 2019 and and
right now it's really hard to follow
the base at which everything is released
but the transformers library has i think
60 different architectures now
and is trying to to add them as soon as
the papers are released
um and so what we're going to look at
here is not
what's inside the transformer model in
details in details
but a little bit of an overview and
there are
three types of transformer models which
we're going to explore in
this section so there are gptd
model uh gpt-like model that are called
encoders or
auto regressive models which are
transformer models that are best fitted
to generate text look so what we were
talking about
before like when you your your phone is
trying to
to suggest you uh ideas of words that
you could put
in the sentence afterward the other type
of transformer model is the bert light
model
gpt-like sorry it's not an encoders
model it's a decoders model
sorry autoregressive or decoders models
for gpt but like it's encoder model or
auto-encoding models so those models are
best suited
to classify things so generate a nice
representation of the sentence
which allows you to either classify the
wall sentence classify every
words in the sentence or they also very
good for the extractive question
answering
tasks we we talked about earlier and the
last type of model
are the sequence to sequence transformer
models our encoder decoders model
which has the ones that are better
suited for the sequence to sequence
tasks such as translation summarization
basically writing a new text from a from
an input text
so all those transformer models are
language models and the main difference
between the first two types the encoders
and the decoders is that the decoders
are retrained
by kissing the next word so that's why
they're very good at generating text
because that's way that's how they were
betrayed
whereas the encoders models are usually
pre-trained with feeling
uh some random masks in the sentence so
we have
two examples here
and those transformers models are super
big so we started with like cheap
openage btt
with that were 110 millions of
parameters
and now we have models with like
billions
or tens of billions of parameters
which is why it's very important to
reuse this model
uh which is the whole point of transfer
learning so transfer learning is when
you take a pre-trained model uh which is
huge and what's between
lots and lots of amount of data which
took a lot of compute
so a lot of electrical power unlimited a
lot of co2
and you reuse that model to fine tune it
on a new task the task that you
you want to work with and um
and yeah so by reusing the model instead
of trading a new one from scratch uh
your economy
you are you you have you're saving
compute
uh you're saving money and you need less
uh less data
than what the model was retrained on hbc
there are
new questions
uh there is one question is gpt3 the
only model that allows you to do zero
shot learning
[Music]
so that is of this model was advertised
it's not the only one because t5 for
instance has the same kind of
prompt where you tell it for instance
summarize this text or translate this
text from this language to this language
and so it can also do some sort of zero
shot learning
and there's a link to the notebooks but
it was answered already
so let's go uh and watch the transfer
learning video i hope this one is going
to be a little bit better than the
previous one
and or more in the chat we'll share the
link if you want to watch it directly
if it's too laggy
what is transfer learning
the idea of transfer learning is to
leverage the knowledge required by a
model trend with lots of data
on another task the model a will be
trained specifically for task a
now let's say you want to train model b
for a different task
one option would be to train the model
from scratch
this could take lots of computation time
and data
instead we could initialize model b with
the same weights
as model a transferring the knowledge of
model a
on task b when training from scratch
all the model's weights are initialized
randomly
in this example we are training a birth
model on the task of recognizing if two
sentences
are similar or not on the left
it's trained from scratch and on the
right it's fine tuning a pre-trained
model
as we can see using transfer learning on
the pre-trained model yields better
results
and it doesn't matter if you train
longer the training from scratch is kept
around 70 accuracy
or the retrain model beats the 86
percent easily
this is because retrain models are
usually trained on large amounts of data
but provides a model with a statistical
understanding of the language used
during pre-training
in computer vision transfer learning has
been applied successfully
for almost 10 years models are
frequently retrained on imagenet
a dataset containing 1.2 millions of
photo images
each image is specified by one of 1000
levels
training like this on labeled data is
called
supervised learning in natural language
processing
transfer learning is a bit more recent a
key difference with imagenet
is that the training is usually
self-supervised
which means it doesn't require us
imagination for the labels
a very common retraining objective is to
guess the next word in a sentence
which only requires lots and lots of
text gpd2 for instance
was retrained this way using the content
of 45 million links posted by users
on reddit another example of
self-supervised per training objective
is to predict the value of randomly
masked words which is similar to feeling
less belonging tests you may have done
in school
but was retrained this way using the
english wikipedia app
and health 11000 and published books
in practice transfer learning is applied
on a given model
by throwing away its head that is its
last layers focused on the training
objective
and replacing it with a new randomly
initialized ad
suitable for the task attempt for
instance
when fine-tuning the bird model earlier
removes the advert classified maskwort
and replaced it with a classifier with
two outputs since our tasks
add two levels to be as efficient as
possible
the pre-trained model used should be as
similar as possible to the task it's
fine tuned on
for instance if the problem is to
classify german sentences
it's best to use the german free trade
model
but with the good comes the pad the
pre-trained model does not only transfer
its knowledge
but also any bias it may contain
imagenet mostly contains images coming
from the united states and western
europe
the models fine tuned with it usually
will perform better on images from these
countries
open ai also studied the bias in the
prediction of its gpt3 model
which was between using the guests and
x-word objective
changing the gender of the prompt from
e-raspberry to
she was query changed the predictions
from mostly neutral objectives
to almost only physical ones in the
model card of the gpt2 model
open ai also acknowledges its bias and
discourages its use
in systems that interact with humans
okay so let me see if there are any
questions on the video
i don't think so
okay so this was uh
what transfer learning is a very high
level introductions
and this is what's usually done with
transformers model
and for instance the model we used
before distilled bert
fine-tuning this is to english i'm
forgetting alphabet sleep
as it's as the name indicates it was
fine-tuned
on the 62 data set which is a data set
containing
sentences and you have to classify them
between positive and negative
and unless there are any
new questions i don't think so uh we're
ready to
dive into the transformer architecture a
little bit more so omar will post the
link of that video in the chat
uh i hope it's not too laggy again so
this video is going to introduce the
difference between encoder decoders and
sequence to sequence
transformer model we briefly talked
about before
let's study the transformer architecture
this video is the introductory video to
the encoders
decoders and encoder decoder series of
videos
in the series we'll try to understand
what makes a transformer network
and we'll try to explain it in simple
high-level terms
no advanced understanding of human
networks is necessary but
an understanding of basic vectors and
tensors may help
to get started we'll take up this
diagram from the original transformer
paper
entitled attention is all you need by
bazwani
as we'll see here we can leverage only
some parts of it according to what we're
trying to do
we want to dive into the specific layers
building up that architecture
but we'll try to understand the
different ways this architecture can be
used
let's first start by splitting that
architecture into two parts
on the left we have the encoder and on
the right the decoder
these two can be used together but they
can also be used independently
let's understand how these work the
encoder accepts inputs that represent
text
it converts these texts these words into
numerical representations
these numerical representations can also
be called embeddings or
features we'll see that it uses the
self-attention mechanism as its main
component
and we recommend you check out the video
on encoders specifically to understand
what is this numerical presentation
as well as how it works we'll study the
self-retention mechanism in more detail
as well as its bidirectional properties
the decoder is similar to the encoder it
can also accept
text inputs it uses a similar mechanism
as the encoder
which is the masked self-attention as
well it differs from the encoder due to
its united directional feature
and is traditionally used in an
auto-regressive manner
here too we recommend you check out the
video on decoders especially to
understand how all of this works
combining the two parts results in what
is known as an encoder decoder or a
sequence to sequence transformer
the encoder accepts inputs and computes
a high level representation of those
inputs
these outputs are then passed to the
decoder the decoder uses the encoder's
outputs alongside other inputs to
generate a prediction
and then predict an output which is what
we use in future
iterations hence the term autoregressive
finally to get an understanding of
encoders decoders as a whole
we recommend you check out the video on
encoder decoders
okay so that was the general
introduction
and so basically this is the diagram you
have to remember
about the general transformers
architecture and
so what is an encoder a decoder or an
encoder decoder model
uh we'll dive into that a little bit
more just before going there
uh we briefly talked
about attention uh which was in the
diagram for the original paper so the
the core of the architecture the
transformer model is this layer called
multi-head attention which is a layer
that basically as an indicates base
attention
so it's gonna look at your wall sentence
sequence of input and for each word it's
going to compute
some score uh deleting to pay attention
uh to this or this word of this of our
world
so why is that it's because the
transformer architecture was
originally designed for translation and
when you're translating
uh if you're translating a given word
you
you need that word but you need to
understand the context around it
so for instance you might need the
gender
of if the words the non-human needed
gender which would be the word before
you may need some words after um
so that's attention layer is there
on top of computing some contextual
representation
of the of a given world it's there to
tell the model
for this specific word pay also in
attention to this one in particular
this one is not so useful but this one
you should really
pay attention to it we all
have videos coming in section two and
section three of the course that go
into more details of what the attention
layer is but that's
as a level introduction and the key
difference
between encoders and decoders is that in
encoders the attention mechanism
is allowed to look at every word in the
sentence so the word before
and the word after that's because like
support model
when you need to detect
sorry to guess what is the value of a
mask word uh it's useful
to look at what was before and also that
was after
as decoders models like gpt have to
predict the next word so if they were
allowed to look at the word after it
would be cheating
so in those models the attention layer
is only allowed to look at what was
before
in the sentence so for instance when
trying to guess silver
as the attention layer can only look at
my name and ease we can't look at what
was
what he's after in the sentence
so we are going to switch to the next
section of this chapter on oculus models
but before that let me see if there are
any questions
on the decoder diagram what does the
output shifted right refer to please
let me check that there grab
ah this so that's because
here we are
training a translation model remember
this is the original architecture of the
transformer model
so when you translate a phrase a
sentence in english
and the output is sentenced in french so
here
the labels your this part of the
transformer model is the decoder and it
will try
to guess the next word so it's going to
begin with nothing
and then see when to try to begin the
first word of the sentence then it will
have the first word of the sentence to
try to begin to guess the second one of
the sentence
then it will have the first words and
sometimes to get the third one in the
sentence etcetera etcetera
and so that's what the shifted write
means it means that
here we have the output so the text in
the in the desired language
shifted one token to the right
and another question was can you provide
a quick
overview intuition of oh a digital
version of a model
like this gilbert is able to maintain
high accuracy
while being significant significantly
sorry
more lightweight so quick overview
intuition sure
in general transformer models or deep
learning models have
lots of parameters several millions but
a lot of those parameters
are either redundant or necessary not
necessarily really
really useful environment so
for instance uh there is a lot of
research into pruning
uh transformers networks so pruning
means
removing some of those weights to be
able to go faster
especially at difference distillation is
another way of reducing the size
so the process is to have a smaller
model
try to get the same output as a bigger
and it works reasonably well to still
have some good performance so that's
because
the intuition behind it is that the very
big model has lots of parameters
but not all of those parameters are
really useful
and so let's dive into the encoders
model so we have
three more videos encoders decoders and
then sequence to sequence more
let me put it in full screen and design
in this video we'll study the encoder
architecture
an example of a popular encoder only
architecture is bert which is the most
popular model of its kind let's first
start by understanding how it works
we'll use a small example using three
words we use these as inputs and pass
them through the encoder
we retrieve a numerical representation
of each word
here for example the encoder converts
those three words welcome to nyc
in these three sequences of numbers
the encoder outputs exactly one sequence
of numbers
per input word this numerical
representation
can also be called a feature vector or a
feature tensor
let's dive in this representation it
contains one vector per word that was
passed
through the encoder each of this vector
is a numerical representation of the
word in question
the dimension of that vector is defined
by the architecture of the model
for the base birth model it is 768.
these representations contain the value
of a word but contextualized
for example the vector attributed to the
word to
isn't the representation of only the two
word
it also takes into account the words
around it
which we call the context as in it looks
to the
left context the words on the left of
the one we're studying
here the word welcome and the context on
the right
here the word nyc and it outputs a value
for the word
given its context it is therefore a
contextualized value
one could say that the vector of 768
values
holds the meaning of the word within the
text
it does this thanks to the
self-attention mechanism
the self-attention mechanism relates to
different positions
or different words in a single sequence
in order to compute a representation
of that sequence as we've seen before
this means that the resulting
representation of a word has been
affected by
other words in the sequence
we won't dive into these specifics here
but we'll offer some further readings if
you want to get a better understanding
at what happens under the hood
so when should one use an encoder
encoders can be used as standalone
models in a wide variety of tasks
for example bert arguably the most
famous transformer model
is a standalone encoder model and at the
time of release it beat the state of the
art
in many sequence classification tasks
question answering tasks
and masked language modeling to only
cite a few
the idea is that encoders are very
powerful at extracting
vectors that carry meaningful
information about a sequence
this vector can then be handled down the
road by additional neurons to make sense
of them
let's take a look at some examples where
encoders really shine
first of all masked language modeling or
mlm
it's the task of predicting a hidden
word in a sequence of words
here for example we have hidden the word
between mai and is
this is one of the objectives with which
bert was trained it was
trained to predict hidden words in a
sequence
encoders shine in this scenario in
particular as bi-directional information
is crucial here
if we didn't have the words on the right
is it silva and the dot then there is
very little chance that bert would have
been able to identify name
as the correct word the encoder needs to
have a good understanding of the
sequence in order to predict a masked
word
as even if the text is grammatically
correct
it does not necessarily make sense in
the context of the sequence
as mentioned earlier encoders are good
at doing sequence classification
sentiment analysis is an example of
sequence classification
the model's aim is to identify the
sentiment of a sequence
it can range from giving a sequence a
rating from one to five stars if doing
review analysis
to giving a positive or negative rating
to a sequence
which is what is shown here for example
here given the two sequences
we use the model to compute a prediction
and to classify the sequences
among these two classes positive and
negative
while the two sequences are very similar
containing the same words
the meaning is entirely different and
the encoder model is able to grasp that
difference
so that so that was it for encoders
model
some examples are albert bert
d silbert elektra roberta
let's have a look at the next section
which is going to be
about decoders and just before that let
me check if there are any questions
i don't see any new questions in the
chat don't forget
that you can ask any questions in the
chat that's kind of the point of having
the live the live session
in this video we'll study the decoder
architecture
an example of a popular decoder only
architecture is gpt2
in order to understand how decoders work
we recommend taking a look at the video
regarding encoders
they're extremely similar to decoders
one can use a decoder for most of the
same tasks as an encoder
albeit with generally a little loss of
performance
let's take the same approach we have
taken with the encoder to try and
understand the architectural differences
between an encoder and a decoder
we'll use a small example using three
words we pass them through their decoder
we retrieve a numerical representation
for each word
here for example the decoder converts
the three words
welcome to nyc in these three sequences
of numbers
the decoder outputs exactly one sequence
per input word this numerical
representation
can also be called a feature vector or a
feature tensor
let's dive in this representation it
contains one vector per word that was
passed
through the decoder each of these
vectors is a numerical representation of
the word in question
the dimension of that vector is defined
by the architecture of the model
where the decoder differs from the
encoder is principally with its
self-attention mechanism
it's using what is called masked
self-attention
here for example if we focus on the word
two we'll see that this vector is
absolutely unmodified by the nyc word
that's because all the words on the
right also known as the right context of
the word
is masked rather than benefiting from
all the words on the left
and right so the bidirectional context
decoders only have access to a single
context
which can be the left context or the
right context
the masked self-attention mechanism
differs from the self-attention
mechanism
by using an additional mask to hide the
context on either side of the word
the words numerical representation will
not be affected by the words in the
hidden context
so when should one use ad code decoders
like encoders
can be used as standalone models as they
generate a numerical representation
they can also be used in a wide variety
of tasks
however the strength of a decoder lies
in the way a word can only have access
to its left context
having only access to their left context
they're inherently good at text
generation
the ability to generate a word or a
sequence of words
given a known sequence of words this is
known as causal language modeling
or natural language generation
here's an example of how causal language
modeling works
we start with an initial word which is
my
we use this as input for the decoder
the model outputs a vector of numbers
and this vector contains information
about the sequence which is here a
single word
we apply a small transformation to that
vector so that it maps to all the words
known by the model which is a mapping
that we'll see later
called a language modeling head we
identify that the model believes that
the most
probable following word is name
we then take that new word and add it to
the initial sequence
from my we are now at my name this is
where the
autoregressive aspect comes in
autoregressive models
reuse their past outputs as inputs and
the following steps
once again we do the exact same
operation
we cast that sequence through the
decoder and retrieve the most probable
following word
in this case it is the word is
we repeat the operation until we're
satisfied
starting from a single word we've now
generated a full sentence
we decide to stop there but we could
continue for a while
gpt2 for example has a maximum context
size of
1024 we could eventually generate up to
a
1024 words and the decoder would still
have some memory of the first words in
the sequence
okay
let me look at some questions on
the decoders model oh there's one
question is it possible to use larger
sentences more than 512 words as inputs
for
encoders great question so
it depends but most of the time no for
instance pert
has a maximum length of 512 so
you can't use larger sentences than that
um some newer models like long former
for instance can accept
a longer context so you should
look at the documentation but foods
would be very specific
on colors like not all encoders can do
that
another thing that you can do is split
your sentence
into several parts of 512 words
and then you get a representation you
pass it
you pass each of those chunk to the
model so you get a representation for
each of those checks
and you can for instance average uh what
you get at the end
uh to try uh to train a classifier
for for larger sentences but that's kind
of the only way
either a specific model that has been
trained to have longer inputs such as
long former
or splitting your inputs in bits
so another questions how does
how does a mask language modeling
objective deal with longer words
that end up being a multi-token world
example c
plane with paper becomes c
plane so you will see about that for
those who are more beginners you will
see about that separation in the in the
next chapter
with the tokenizers video if not using
world war masking then the model can
cheat and see parts of the longer world
so that is absolutely correct and that's
why you will see that you have several
versions of pert
there is one that has been pre-trained
with all world masking
and another one that has been trained
without that
it's would be cheating for the ash ash
plane
because the model i mean it would be it
would be where cause we're
kissing c
sorry uh when you've got the ash hash
plane in the context uh
when you're trying to guess ash ash
plane and you've got to shift because
in the context it's less cheating
because the model has to guess that the
model did not handle
but it's true that using worldwide
masking would remove that kind of
specific bias and cheating with them
with the apostrophes
okay so let's look at the last video and
then i'll answer to more questions after
the last video
uh on sequence to sequence uh
transformer models which combine
both the encoders and the decoders
in this video we'll study the encoder
decoder architecture
an example of a popular encoder decoder
model is t5
in order to understand how the encoder
decoder works
we recommend you check out the videos on
encoders and decoders as
standalone models understanding how they
work individually
will help understanding how an encoder
decoder works let's start from what
we've seen about the encoder
the encoder takes words as inputs casts
them through the encoder and retrieves a
numerical representation
for each word cast through it we now
know that
that this numerical representation holds
information about the meaning of the
sequence
let's put this aside and add the decoder
to the diagram
in this scenario we're using the decoder
in a manner that we haven't seen before
we're passing the outputs of the encoder
directly to it
additionally to the encoder output we
also give the decoder a sequence
when prompting the decoder for an output
with no initial sequence
we can give it the value that indicates
the start of a sequence
and that's where the encoder decoding
magic happens
the encoder accepts a sequence as input
it computes a prediction and outputs a
numerical representation
then it sends that over to the decoder
it has in a sense encoded that sequence
and the decoder in turn using this input
alongside its usual sequence
input will take a stab at decoding the
sequence
the decoder decodes the sequence and
outputs a word
as of now we don't really need to make
sense of that word but we can understand
that the decoder is essentially decoding
what the encoder has output
the start of sequence here the start of
sequence word here indicates that it
should start decoding the sequence
now that we have both the encoder
numerical representation
and an initial generated word we don't
need the encoder anymore
as we have seen before with the decoder
it can act in an
autoregressive manner the word it has
just output can now be used as an
input this in combination with the
numerical representation
output by the encoder can now be used to
generate a second word
please note that the first word is still
here as the model still outputs it
however we have graded out as we have no
need for it anymore
we can continue on and on for example
until the decoder outputs a value that
we consider a stopping value
like a dot meaning the end of a sequence
here we've seen the full mechanism of
the encoder decoder transformer
let's go over it one more time we have
an initial sequence that is sent to the
encoder
that encoder output is then sent to the
decoder for it to be decoded
while it can now discard the encoder
after a single use
the decoder will be used several times
until we have
generated every word that we need
so let's see a concrete example with
translation language modeling
also called transduction which is the
act of translating a sequence
here we would like to translate this
english sequence welcome to nyc
in french we're using a transformer
model
that is trained for that task explicitly
we use
the encoder to create a representation
of the english sentence
we cast this to the decoder with the use
of the start of sequence word we ask it
to output the first word
it outputs b avenue which means welcome
and we then use bienvenue as the input
sequence for the decoder
this alongside the encoder numerical
representation
allows the decoder to predict the second
word ah which is two in english
finally we ask the decoder to predict a
third word
it predicts nyc which is correct we've
translated the
the sentence where the encoder decoder
really shines is that we have an encoder
and a decoder
which often do not share weights
therefore we have an entire block the
encoder that can be trained to
understand the sequence
and extract the relevant information for
the translation scenario we've seen
earlier for example
this would mean parsing and
understanding what was said in the
english language it would mean
extracting information from that
language
and putting putting all of that in a
vector dense in information
on the other hand we have the decoder
whose sole purpose is to decode the
numerical representation
output by the encoder this decoder can
be specialized in a completely different
language
or even modality like images or speech
encoders decoders are special for
several reasons
firstly they're able they're able to
manage sequence to sequence tasks
like translation that we have just seen
secondly the ways between the encoder
and the decoder parts are not
necessarily shared let's take another
example of translation
here where translating transformers are
powerful in french
firstly this means that from a sequence
of three words
we're able to generate a sequence of
four words
one could argue that this could be
handled with a decoder
that would generate the translation in
an auto regressive manner
and they would be right
another example of where sequence to
sequence transformers shine is in
summarization
here we have very a very long sequence
generally a full text
and we want to summarize it since the
encoder and decoders are separated
we can have different context lengths
for example a very long context for the
encoder
which handles the text and a smaller
context for the decoder which handles
the summarized sequence
there are a lot of sequence to sequence
models this contains a few examples of
popular encoder decoder models available
in the transformers library
additionally you can load an encoder and
a decoder
inside an encoder decoder model
therefore according to the specific task
you're targeting
you may choose to use specific encoders
and decoders which have proven their
worth
on these specific tasks
okay so let's see if you have any
questions
oh okay this par freezing kind of
decoder problem or both encoder decoder
problem
and is is there any pipeline available
for same
so paraphrasing so generating a similar
task to the input
will be more like an encoder decoder
problem however
it seems that it's going to be very hard
to train a model
on that task specifically because it's
going to have a tendency to
to want to output the same thing it
received
unless you want to paraphrase in another
style for instance going from formal
style to very casual style there is no
pipeline available for that task
out of the box in the transformers
library
so let's go to the next section of
chapter 1 which is the last section
of the chapter and talk a little bit
about bias
and limitations of the transformer
models
so like any deep learning model
in general transformers are just one
specific case but
it's really a problem for for all kind
of deploying model
um so they are powerful tools and
as you know probably if you take a deep
learning introduction course
ever power photos but you don't really
control or they get from the inputs
to the output this was more controlled
by the training
they got and the training data they
received
but if you don't
take any precautions you can have those
models
make predictions that you don't
necessarily want in the
the app you're deploying so for instance
um
let's just have a very quick look at
what bert
which has been retrained on the
objective of filling math squad
and just have a similar example to the
one we saw in the transfer learning
video with gpt
where we just changed the gender of the
sentence so
if we put this man works as a guess the
word
or this woman works as against the world
for men we get like some kind of neutral
uh
jobs probably more steroids
stereotypically
steroid stereotypically male
for women uh we get very stereotypically
uh female jobs uh and prostitutes which
is
not necessarily something we would want
our model to output as one of the top
five possibilities
uh so and that model was not trained on
data that was particularly uh flagged uh
as um problematic uh more like usually
considered neutral
it's only uh wikipedia and a corpus
of unpublished books so
you have to be like gpt for instance is
more known because it's been trained of
kind of the wall of the internet
according to edit users
which is considered a little bit
more sexist or
oxidophobic uh or things like that so
you have to be very careful because that
bias is in the pre-trained model
uh so this is done with the birthplaced
case checkpoint
specifically and completely reproducible
because there is no randomness in the
prediction so if you go in a notebook
and try that you're going to get those
results
so this is present in any model in some
way or another and it's also going to
persist
after your fan tuning so you have always
have to be super careful that
when you function your model in your
training data there are going to be
enough samples
of the outputs you'd like to see and you
should always roll out
your model into production by taking
some care to to analyze the results
that you get and potentially if you see
that you have some predictions you would
like to avoid try to to correct your
training data to add more samples
[Music]
to it more samples that would correct
the base of your model
and that's it for chapter one let me see
if there are
less more questions on the in the chat
otherwise
uh okay we're gonna be ready to to tune
out
uh so once uh you have finished this
video don't hesitate to take the quiz
i'm not gonna do that
on the video uh to be sure that you
understood all the terms
that were all the content sorry that we
saw in this chapter
there are two live stations that you can
find again
on the forum this is not the forum
anymore
there are two live sessions next week
for chapter two be sure to try and widen
the over so
there's gonna be one with me and next
wednesday hopefully all the technical
issues will be resolved
because i'm gonna take a little bit of
care uh to make sure
it works a little bit better especially
for the videos and so
the first one is going to be with lewis
on morning european time on wednesday
and the second one is going to be
on next first day at the same time as
this one um
take the time to create an account on
the give facehub to play with the
hopefully the bug in collapse is going
to be solved very soon and you can play
with all the code
on that platform otherwise you can
always use um
the inference um api on the website
and uh also think about
a project that you'd like to to run a
and to try your skills and as you learn
more
using the course so anything related to
text classification because that's
what we'll focus in this part of the
course but try to think of yeah what
what kind of model you would like to
build
doing something that you could then
share with the community
and then in the next three sections will
help you with the course too
to do that in practice let me check one
last time with our
questions
and yeah i think that's kind of
all okay thanks a lot for following
and see you next week
you